I don't know much about politics I
really don't I don't know much about
politics I don't I don't like to talk
about how you know Trump is just a
[__] lunatic you know he is naturally
I don't talk about it that much because
I just I stay out of politics this is
not political okay what the [__] is Joe
Biden ever saying okay what is he saying
sure I saw
that made me aware when I was in law
school proudly for Holloway okay proudly
for your dad okay first African-American
state senator in the state of in the
state of Delaware everything about there
we go okay good good nice claps good
claps good good and by the way
went off the teleprompter went off the
[__] that was designed what he was going
to say all of his handlers right now are
going like this right now in the back of
them going off course stick to the plan
okay but when he says by the way when
Joe Biden says by the way
more like it's like that's like when
superimposed when he says by the way
[__] the planes flying into the
[__] Twin Towers like that's what it
is
superimposed polling just going down and
down and down
by the way but by the way you know first
African-American we love everybody and
this and that by the way by the way
okay
and by the way you know I sit on the
stand okay and it get hot I got a lot of
I got hairy legs what
you said that
where the [__] is this going now when
somebody says something as wacky as [__]
as that when you're talking politics and
when you're running for president okay
and you just divert all right you just
show up to the pool party with a speedo
on right and everyone's like whoa whoa
whoa what's going on
you better have something in store like
it's a [__] the end of an M Night
Shyamalan movie okay
you better be this guy
you better have the deck
stacked
but Joe Biden is just jumping out of the
plane with Skittles
and then people are like why you got
those Skittles and he's like well
because you can eat them on the way down
and you're like but you're gonna die
what
and then you open up your shoot and he's
just like
but it's less tasty
and you're like that guy didn't think it
out did he
you're jumping out of a plane with a
[__] pocket full of Skittles you
[__]
okay let me just go back
and it get hot I got a lot of I got
hairy legs
and it get hot first of all he knows
he's [__] up already but he's into it
and he's like I could do it it's an ego
thing because he's stuttering she's like
he's already knows he shouldn't say the
hairy legs thing but but he's like I'm
Joe Biden I made it this far
the stand and it get hot I got a lot of
I got hairy legs that turned that that
that that that that that that turn uh
about um blonde in the Sun
is this a [__]
Daniel Bedingfield song
I gotta
dude
get hot I got a lot of I got hairy legs
that turned that that that that that
that that that turn uh
um blonde in the sun and the kids used
to come up and reach in the pool and rub
my leg down so it was traded and then
watched the hair come back up again okay
okay they look at it so I learned about
roaches I learned about kids jumping on
my lap uh and I love kids jumping on my
lap
and I tell you what the men they're now
all men the guys I work with down here
and they're all guys at the time
they're all good men
most of them made an awful lot of
themselves and Earl Larkin had a rough
time and some of you new Earl I came
back as a public defender uh what you
just said
is one of the most insanely idiotic
things I have ever heard that's [__]
thing from what do you call it what is
it from
Adam Sandler blue Madison
um
God I mean just
wow
just
I got and I cannot no no I gotta I gotta
I got a hairy legs and I used to be in a
pool and I used to be in a pool and I
would and I would have kids and and the
kids would would be in a pool and they
would they would rub my legs down and
and to straight to straighten the hair
and then they would let Let It Go and
they would and they would watch it and
their hair would just curl up okay so I
know about roaches ah
a what
so and I love having kids on my lap ah
but you're running for president so you
can't say that stuff
the thing is though
no
the thing is though you're jumping out
of an airplane with a pocket full of
Skittles
s is that you're a jumping out of a
plane with a pocket full of Skittles
that song dude Jason Derulo is in cats
oh for [__] sake dude
that song wiggle wiggle wiggle